êtes capable de vous traversez le corps
avec un sabre laser laser voit la star
wars tabac ou les deux démonstrations
d'affection hollande maintient un max de
bruit
[Applaudissements]
wendy vous pouvez baisser les lumières
évidemment
et vous fait pas mal alors ne le fait
pas chez vous c'est pas une blague
les enfants on va faire c'est un prof on
ne reproduit pas ça chez soi vous
regarder star wars mais c'est de toute
façon déjà pour trouver un sabre oui on
me dit bon c'est julien hormis valeur de
symbole après toi la gorge passion à la
halle aux dieux et non vous faites la
fête une blague
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chic se tenir on peut dire de quel côté